[Music]
there are two things everybody knows
about new york city
it's got tall buildings
and a lot of people
some of them are even fans
what's up how you doing
and they come from all walks of life i
wanted to say thank you for your service
but what most people don't know
it's a great place to fish
oh my gosh this thing is giant it's the
ultimate urban fishing experience did
you just catch one
in one of the greatest cities on earth
there you go
i'm mike iaconelli my friends and i grew
up fishing the mean streams and rivers
of philadelphia
now i'm a professional angler
with a screaming passion
for city fishing
all it takes is a little skill and a
local
to show you where the fish are biting
new york new york
it's the city that never sleeps
which is fine by me because i'm here to
do some serious fishing that's right
fishing
people assume new york city is just a
concrete jungle but it's much more than
that this place is surrounded by water
hudson river east river jamaica bay and
with all that water there's amazing
fishing opportunities right here in the
city
the best way to see just how much water
there is in this city is to head across
one of its bridges there are over 2 000
bridges and tunnels in the new york city
metro area
[Music]
but this one is the most famous
the brooklyn bridge
[Music]
new york city was colonized by the dutch
in the early days it was a fur trading
post and like most other cities fishing
was a huge part of the history of this
city and it's a big part of the economy
today
and i went in on that action before i
leave the big apple
i've picked three of new york's finest
as my bucket list fish the striped bass
the fluke and the blue fish
they're not gonna be easy to catch but
they're somewhere in this city
first up on my bucket list the state
saltwater fish of new york the striped
bass
they're native to north america's
atlantic coast from canada to florida
and are often called stripers
they're nothing like the freshwater bass
i catch and they can be huge
to give an example a world-class
largemouth bass weighs like 20 pounds
but stripers
they can grow in excess of 50 pounds or
bigger
this is the time of the year to catch
him in new york
it's the most iconic fish in new york
and my goal today is to jack me a
striper
so i'm in chelsea on the hudson river
meeting up with my buddy frank and we're
going to chase one of these monsters
frank hey good morning good morning come
on awesome appreciate it
it's a good thing frank has got a boat
that can handle these waves cause the
hudson is chopping people don't believe
me when i say
listen it's going to be rough here but
when we get in the ocean
[Music]
it's the reverse so what they normally
do
the hudson river is about 315 miles long
and flows north to south
it starts in upstate new york and
eventually drains into the atlantic
ocean between new york city and jersey
city
the river is named after henry hudson an
englishman sailing for the dutch east
india company who explored it in 1609
the mouth of the hudson is also home to
one of the most famous women in the
world
her name
lady liberty
this makes me just want to take my hat
off just for a second i'm serious i feel
very patriotic right now
as you should
for every american the statue symbolizes
liberty and freedom
but for immigrants arriving in thousands
of boats this symbolized the beginning
of a new life
my grandfather came in from italy how
35 days or whatever it took them to come
across that ocean and then they come in
this harbor and they see that thing and
they think like i made it it's
unbelievable you know yeah
ellis island was the first stop for many
this is where they were processed and
began a new life in america
of starting it's time to get fishing
we're headed out under the verrazano
bridge
but before we try for striper we're
going to catch some of their favorite
food a bait fish called bunker
this is a really cool part of fishing
that you don't get to see a lot
a lot of times you're buying bait from
the store but this is this is part of
the whole experience catching your own
bait
you've got to master the technique of of
knowing how to throw these things
bunkers swim in schools tightly packed
and close to the surface in good weather
so they're easy to see
but getting a net on top of them
oh boy not so much
bro
this is a very ancient type of fishing
that might have been a vented more than
2 000 years ago
the throne that's a really tough thing
to master you've got to get that net out
there straight so it falls down and
you've got to get right on top of the
school's bunker
success
good job bro
wow
fellas
we hit pay dirt
look at that
[Music]
let me tell you something
i pride myself on being a good fisherman
but i couldn't catch these fish
not like that they were hard
and that's bunker and that is striper
food right there it sucks to be a bunker
and this is
part of the process of being a
successful fisherman is catching your
own bait and that's how it's done right
there
i can't do it
with a boat full of bunker it's time to
head to an area with some cover
structure to see if this live bait will
snag me a striper
we're heading to a pair of small
artificial islands just off staten
island that are great fishing spots
this is the right kind of area
you can tell by the current breaks
points of islands
hoffman island is about 10 acres in size
and is a man-made island
it was built in the late 1800s to
prevent disease from striking new york
city if you came into ellis island and
you look sick yeah they quarantined you
here on this island
packed together on unhygienic ships many
immigrants were exposed to infectious
diseases like scarlet fever typhoid and
measles if you looked sick city
authorities would isolate you on this
small artificial island
hard to believe there were up to 3 000
people living here
and if you were sick you went to the
other island swinburne see that smoke
stack
yeah
that was the crematorium wow
swinburne held the hospital where people
either got better or died
both islands are basically large rock
piles
perfect habitats for striped bass
but our live bait has yet to do the
trick and i think i know what the
problem is
this weather is beautiful it's gorgeous
it's in the 70s it's calm it's flat
for fishermen this is
awesome but for fishing sometimes this
calm weather can hurt you the striper
get a a better look at everything
they're more cautious
let's go to the other island
nothing around hoffman island time to
head over to swinburne
just under a mile away
and pilings look good we call that the
hot corner mike
old wharf pilings are a classic place
for fish to gather
but it's creepy to think that this wharf
is where thousands of sick immigrants
stepped off their ferries and entered a
quarantined hospital
and some never made it any further
[Music]
come on give me a break
i promise you'll go back
talking to the fish
oh frank talking to the fish first signs
of insanity
i think i'm past the first signs a long
time ago
that's about perfect
i got one
yeah yeah
this fish could be the striper i'm
looking for but it's putting up a hell
of a fight if it gets away i might never
know he's hooked to the pilot i can't
get him out
[Music]
i'm in new york city trying to catch a
striped bass i got one
yeah and something just hit my line like
a ton of bricks
it's got me wrapped up in the pilot
he's hooked to the pilot i can't get him
out
i gotta
i got him got about that piling
yeah they're not largemouth we don't
usually listen like that
that was a battle
he had me in that piling
oh man
look at that
and that's what we've come to new york
for
the striped bass
look how pretty that thing is look at
the color
silver a little bit of blue
they call these things line ciders look
at the black
horizontal lines
down its body
one of those lines is a pressure
sensitive lateral line that helps the
bass detect sound waves and vibrations
helping them track their prey
the other nickname for these things are
silver bullets
and you can tell how that thing's built
it's long and lean
these things are built for speed look at
those dorsal fins on the top
the size and power of these fish are
what makes them a favorite among sports
fishermen they're fearsome predators and
built for speed to chase down their prey
back in colonial times the pilgrims fish
for these things to eat for food
when you think about americana you think
about new york you think about it state
saltwater fish and that is the striped
bass
all right we're gonna let this fish go
there she goes
we made it happen man
tough day i i calm sunny wary fish and
we still made it happen and dude it did
everything it could to get away from you
it tried
but you got it
i've caught my striper that's one bucket
list fish down
now it's time to head back to manhattan
and plan the next move
i'm going to take a break from my bucket
list today and enjoy some time in the
big apple
and i know just where to start
we're going to go to my favorite pizza
place in the world
lombardi's
lombardi's is the oldest pizzeria in
america it was established in 1905.
but what does pizza have to do with
fishing
let's find out
man this place smells great
i've been known to polish off an entire
pie here back in the day but there's one
pizza topping tradition i'm ashamed to
say i've never tried
anchovy
mike did you want to put anything with
the anchovies you just want to leave it
durian shelby straight up anchovy
believe it or not i've used anchovy as
bait before to catch bluefish and sea
bass it's really an acquired taste
anchovy are small forage fish found
mostly in marine waters
traditionally they are gutted salted and
brine and packed in oil
and we're gonna be eating it in about
three to four minutes
that quick that's it brother wow
they have a strong salty flavor so you
either hate them or love them
cheers
come on
oh awesome you've been missing out all
these years to have my first anchovy on
a pizza at the oldest pizza first in
america the first i appreciate it man
all fishermen are meant to eat anchovies
but right now i'm after something just a
little bigger
i'm heading uptown to the next stop on
my fisherman in the city tour
central park is located in the heart of
manhattan
it was the very first landscape public
park in the u.s
it covers
843 acres and is the most visited city
park in the country i can remember the
first time
i visited central park to go fishing i
was 18.
i hopped the train in jersey backpack
rod and reel
and i came to the center of the city to
catch a bass
there's fishing in lakes
right here
in central park
[Music]
largemouth bass normally spawn in the
spring so it's perfect timing for us
this cover that i found is where they
like to protect their young
right now what i'm saying
the fish have spawned
what ready look look look
see all that little rain
that's fry that's baby fish
so
you know the things i'm seeing make your
bait choice
a little bit easier so
if i can get something in there
and make it look like it's threatening
the babies that fish will hit it
see
he's got it he's got it
[Music]
there you go
call that shot
and that is
the male
that was guarding that pot of fry the
male is always the smaller of the two
and if you look at it telltale
post-spawn fish fish that has spawned
it's skinny real skinny look how skinny
that is and then you'll see these
little boo-boos little injury marks
where it has guarded from other fish
eating its fry it's had to fan the bed
so a lot of times you see some marks on
the tail we'll let this thing go right
back with its babies
[Music]
there you
go this is insane today
got him
vegan
i mean i can't remember the last time i
fished this lake where it was this on
got him
there you go
this is what urban fishing's all about
big one big one
it's hard to believe that in a busy park
like this you can catch so many fish but
i'm done with bass it's almost too easy
i want to hook something much bigger
common carp can grow up to 88 pounds
that's what i'm talking about
i like to end this day
by freaking out the people at the
restaurant
come on let's go
with such a captive audience watching me
fish i've gotta admit i'm feeling the
pressure
i'm gonna change to a little dough bait
it's almost like a paste
anglers love to use sweet flavored dough
balls called boilies to catch carp
the boilies sit on the bottom and wait
for these fish to suck them up
the fish are hungry my bait keeps coming
off the hook
oh my god dude i've never been this
nervous i feel like i'm in a bass
tournament times 20.
i might have to use a little treble hook
to help keep the dough on there
try one more time and then i might
switch to hooks
there you go
i got it this car must have been waiting
for a handout from the diners but now
he's mine
i got him
i got him
god don't mess this up mike
god don't mess this up mike
i'm in new york city's central park
fishing with a captive audience
and i've got a big carp on my line
i don't want to lose him in front of all
these people please stay on there please
play on there
is this central park special right here
beautiful fish
common carp
here in central park
thank you thank you
this came over from europe the monks
introduced it as a fish food
now these things are prolific in a lot
of the city lakes all across the world
this is what makes
new york city and the park beautiful the
outdoors hiking biking walking rowing
and fishing if you're in the city
give it a try central park new york city
awesome ah my people i guess the only
thing left to do now is to take a bow
tips are greatly appreciated
tips
yeah
i came to new york city with three fish
on my bucket list
and so far i've only got one of them
and the clock is ticking
i better get to work
no fishing trip to new york would be
complete without a visit to montauk
for more than a hundred years new york
city fishermen have been catching the
long island railroad out to the town of
montauk to fish
i'm here
it's 5 a.m on a foggy morning
and i'm here to meet rob
he's the guy who will put me on my next
bucket list fish the fluke fluke are a
very weird flat fish that lie on the
bottom of the ocean staring upwards they
have two eyes both of them on the same
side of their head
montauk lies at the northern tip of long
island
100 miles east of manhattan
and it's a world famous fishing spot
it's legendary for its great white shark
fishing
montauk and its shark fishermen even
helped inspire one of the greatest
fishing stories of all time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but the days of killing great whites are
gone the species is protected
we even now know that montauk is a great
white nursery where they're born and
grow
so i'm not after a giant shark
but i'm here today for the sport fishing
and i want to nail a fluke
they're masters of disguise but that's
not going to stop me from catching one
and ticking it off my bucket list
we just have to find them first
you know this fog is a double-edged
sword it's probably gonna be really good
for the fishing
but as far as navigation and getting to
the spot it's gonna make it tough
lucky for me i have two great locals
captain rob and his main man rudy to
pilot us through all right rob how you
doing yep this is rudy rudy how are you
good to meet you guys you ready yup
we're ready let's go fire her up
this trip could be a bucket list double
header because while we're motoring to
captain rob's fluke fishing grounds
under the montauk lighthouse
we can try for the other fish on my list
the blue fish
so uh what captain rob was saying is uh
he's seen some fish up on top he's gonna
try to get us in like his little school
of bluefish up on top right that's on
your bucket list here so uh let's go
with the light tackle first to start
cool and uh it's always funny to catch
them on the light stops come on you know
if that doesn't work
we'll go to the uh the proven mountain
all right sounds good
fantastic i might be able to catch my
blue fish and cross another bucket fish
off my list
but i've only got a 45 minute window
until the captain powers down and it's
time to switch over to fluke
let's see if we can hook up with
something all right sounds good i'm
ready
and right on cue the sun comes out
that's a good omen
and we're not the only ones fishing out
here
dude there look at them they're like
everywhere
holy hell these birds could mark a
school of bluefish time to saddle up
okay into the barber chair okay
the one thing i know about birds is
they pinpoint
maybe that brother count the five
they pinpoint exactly where the bait's
at
hey
guys
i got something [ __ ] i gotta
put up my fighting chair
i got something i got something
i've come to montauk new york on the
hunt for a weird flatfish called a fluke
but this is something else
this make it's me
we've been trolling for my other bucket
list fish the blue fish and this might
be it
oh it's me i just saw a flash
come on what do we got here
a little bass ah
first fish of montauk
a beautiful striped bass not a blue fish
or a fluke but it's a good start
and it brought company you can see this
look at that
all over a little sea lice
sea lice are a type of parasitic
crustacean that spend most of their
lives living on a fish and feeding off
it they are fairly common and unless
they're present in large numbers aren't
considered harmful to the fish or us
beautiful beautiful striped bass
let's let this thing go
stripers are great but they're not what
i'm here for i need a fluke and we're
almost there
somewhere out here there's a lighthouse
marking our fishing spot
all right that's that's the lighthouse i
just heard something that is the
lighthouse man so we got the fog heart
going right that's music to my ears
foghorn
now that we've arrived at the flute
grounds we need to mix things up change
rigs and start targeting fluke instead
of bluefish
often called chameleons of the sea their
ability to change color and pattern to
what they're lying on is superb
fluke are predators so we gotta provide
action to our baits
so we're using a rig that consists of a
real heavy weight
three to five ounces
we're getting it all the way down on the
bottom and that weight is maintaining
bottom contact and i'm also tipping my
rod a little bit i'm trying to keep that
that bait moving
and those fluke are going to come up
find it suck it in and hopefully we'll
catch one
[Music]
[Music]
you know we've been out here for a
couple hours uh and we're we're hunting
for fluke and the bite's been tough
we've had a few small bites
uh but but no fluke yet and that's our
target species
the tide's changing a little bit right
now so
hopefully things here in the next couple
minutes will pick up
the challenge here is the fish might be
more than 30 feet below us so detecting
the faint hint of a bite at that
distance is really difficult
difficult but not impossible
got them all
right keep round keep around
put that making a net yeah
[Applause]
look at that thing
wow
look at that fluke
now that is what we came the montauk for
right there
wow
look at how cool this fish is
it almost looks like it's like an alien
this thing lays super flat on the bottom
and it's like a chameleon it'll actually
change colors depending on the kind of
bottom it's on if you look here we're on
a rocky gravelly bottom so this fish is
darker on the top and it's actually got
blotches just like the little rocks and
stones
on the bottom but flip this fish around
and look at the bottom
pure white
and that's camouflage as well and when
that fish comes off the bottom
that white belly
blends with the sky and makes that fish
invisible
even more incredible fluke are born with
one eye on each side of their head like
most other animals but as they grow one
eye migrates over the top of the head
twisting the skull in the process
while this is happening the fish changes
from swimming upright to lying on one
side and staring at the sky
what a really amazing fish
we're gonna release this thing so
somebody else can catch it another day
thank you mr fluke thank you montauk
hang on
that was no fluke
that was all skill
[Music]
fish number two is in the bucket these
guys know their stuff
i'd still be lost in the fog
having you on the ball man thanks for
having me i had a blast you too and i
got my flu you did you got your fluke
man
now i've only got one fish left to catch
and i'm in the moon for some blues
it's hard to believe that all this began
with a tiny dutch trading post over 400
years ago
since then it's grown to become home to
over eight and a half million people and
it was the waterways that surrounded the
city that enabled it to grow so fast and
large
i'm getting aboard the governor's island
ferry
headed over to governor's island
there's something amazing happening on
the island right here in new york city
it may be small but governor's island
has got an amazing amount of history
packed into it it's been everything from
a native american fishing camp to a
civil war prison to a training camp for
d-day in world war ii
and today it's home to a program trying
to save new york's most iconic sea
creature the oyster
pete malinowski is growing baby oysters
in these tanks and releasing them back
into new york harbor to clean up the
water pete how are you and help get new
york's oyster population back to where
it was hundreds of years ago so new york
city used to contain half the world's
oysters and when europeans first arrived
there were so many fish in the harbor
that you could catch them just by
lowering a basket over the side of the
boat and bringing it back up full of
fish didn't see fishing rods or anything
like that you didn't need a rod and reel
wow the harbor was full of trillions of
oysters many over a foot long
oyster reefs were the
base for all life right
it attracted the bait the bait attracted
the bigger fish the vegetation
everything was based around oyster reefs
think of it just like a coral reef in a
tropical place they do all the same
things
and oysters became important in the
history of new york city
cheap easily available and nutritious
oysters were the original street food in
new york
huge piles of shells built up and they
were burnt and used as lime and cement
so oysters even helped build the city so
remove them all from the bottom dredged
them up ate them shipped them all over
the world salted and barreled so over
harvesting essentially wiped out the
entire oyster population the water went
from clear to dirty and they were gone
a single oyster can filter up to 50
gallons of water every day
so imagine what billions of them can do
in my mind when you remove something
it's gone for good
but that's not true
well we're trying to figure out how to
restore the oyster reefs to the harbor
so we're working to
put them back pete and his team aim to
transplant one billion oysters back into
new york harbor to restore the reefs
that once dominated the area
so far they've grown and released over
25 million great effort guys
as somebody loves the outdoors and
nature and as a fisherman
i think this is unbelievable i think
it's amazing
anything to help the environment and to
bring more fish into new york city i
love it man
governor's island is also home to a
school and its students have been
helping out with the billion oyster
project they've also formed an
after-school fishing club awesome hey
guys
how you doing hey how are you good how's
the fishing it's all right we got one
we're starting up all right what's your
favorite part of fishing i love the
fight like whenever the fish bite and
that thing
it just gets me hyped up i feel like
that's one of my favorite parts yeah i
love that part yeah what's your favorite
part probably the connection with nature
yeah when you hold the fish you know the
connection you make with it and then you
get to release it swings away it's a
great part yeah yeah oh nice
wait a minute wait a minute that is
wait a minute
did you just catch one
is this a striper yeah
this is awesome
so this is a fishing club all you guys
all you guys live in the city yup why is
it so many
young people so many kids growing up in
the city they don't even believe there's
fish swimming around here what what
would you tell them if you knew a kid
that didn't fish what would you tell him
i feel like you're missing out on one of
the best fishing spots in uh the east
coast oh here i'll let you guys release
it
it's a nice fish by the way
wow nice job
this is exactly how i started i caught
my first fish at the age of six on
philadelphia's schuylkill river it
kick-started my interest in fishing and
look where it's taking me
and when i tell you governor's island
what a cool place
between the billion oyster project and
the kids fishing program this place is
unreal
i wish i could have hung out longer but
i've got to catch a ferry back to
manhattan
i've been fishing my way through the big
apple and now i'm down to the core
one bucket list fish left and just one
day to catch it
i'm here at raritan bay we're in staten
island
as the crow flies we're 15 miles from
times square
[Music]
i'm meeting up with an old buddy of mine
joe mattioli and he's going to try to
put me on a blue fish but not any blue
fish i'm after a gator that means a
giant let's see what happens
[Music]
captain joe marioli has been fishing
around new york city for most of his
life he knows these waters like the back
of his hand
hey mike what's going on what's up man
hey thanks for the call i really
appreciate it how you been i've been
great and yourself good can i come
aboard come on all right
the blue fish i need to catch can be
found from here to europe to africa and
down to australia depending on where you
are they might be called bluefish
fatbach taylor elf or even marine
piranha everywhere they're a prized game
fish famous for their fight
now i know that's good i see birds on
the bank over there
that's a good sign right those are in
turns looks like egg grapes egrets yeah
they're looking for small little bait to
eat they're they're looking for dinner
uh when you see the seagulls diving
that's that's the best okay you can
start casting up front
dude it's gonna be fishing with you
again man
all i need is one willing blue fish on
my line and my bucket list is complete
uh come on bluefish
we don't have 12 hours today
no pressure we only have about six hours
joe all right
we've been there before
the clocks winding down but everything
else is on the up and up i've got the
right man and the right place and even
the right weather
a little breeze cloudy misty you know a
little bit of rain occasionally in the
freshwater bass world we can't wait for
days like this i'm excited about the
conditions but you know at the end of
the day
fish is a living creature that bluefish
doesn't have any rules
i've read the book but the bluefish
doesn't read the book so we'll see what
happens
if i'm going to succeed i need to get
noticed
bluefish attack out of sheer impulse and
usually can't resist noise and commotion
the noisier the better
and your goal is to make as much noise
as you can on the surface
i'm basically i'm trying to make this
bait look like
a struggling bunker
when blue fish hit a big school of
bunker it's mayhem a feeding frenzy even
when their bellies are full the bluefish
keep on killing it's not hard to see why
they're called the marine piranha
really big appetite uh they're super
fast in the water they're quick and once
they chomp down with those teeth
that bait's dead their prey is dead
come on blue fish
come on gator
[Music]
with less than six hours to nail my
final fish
captain joe wants to crank things up by
trolling
trolling is where fishing lines are
dragged behind the boat as it moves
through the water
it's a great way to cover as much ground
as possible bring it up closer to the
water you'll see it but there goes that
flutter in action is what they like
now if i were a blue fish i'd be all
over that lore it's amazing how much
this looks and swims like a bunker
looks good
[Music]
[Laughter]
but the blue fish are still making me
wait
go on going all right here we go
got one
you gotta get it out of there hold it
kick it
good nice one drink it
please be a poo fish
come right at me
that's a blue fist the way he's moving
up i'll come out what's up if you're
trying if it is joe let me get
everything here
until the swivel do i reel the swivel in
or no no no stop right there
hook up lupus blue it's a dry blue fish
okay
it's a blue fish oh please it is please
stay on there please play on there
oh
god
there's plenty more don't worry about it
i'm fishing in raritan bay off of new
york city staten island go on go i'm
going here we go
with a bucket filling blue fish on the
line
oh my god oh god
but this bucket has a leak and my blue
fish just swam away
oh man that's a heartbreaker
ah
that right there is uh
that's the worst feeling in fishing
right there
when you do everything right you work
hard
i'm two days into trying to catch a
bluefish
and literally we have it to the edge of
the boat
we have it right there within our grips
comes off
mike i know what happened what happened
i'll show you
what happened is is he turned on you
remember we saw him yeah
and
the back hook popped off
popped right off
that's what happened when he when he
made that turn
that hook came right off the trailer
hook
and that was it was it was in his mouth
this is what we got left so
you did nothing wrong uh
these fish either
get it on the boat or we lose them we
try again that's all
we're back in the game
we'll get them
i'm banking on joe because he's been
watching his map and has noticed the
pattern
so our goal is to troll up the channel
turn around come back to the same spot
again okay and fish usually hold in one
area and i think we'll be lucky again
all right let's do it
[Music]
you never know you know you don't know
if that's going to be
your only opportunity of the day you
just never know it's fishing but you can
come back through here and get
10 more bites and catch 10 blues in a
row
or
or that could be it you know you just
that's fishing you just never know you
know
i hope that wasn't our last bite of the
day
look at that bend baby spoke soon
whoo
oh it's up it's a big one i saw a jump
at last a blue out of the blue and i
think it's a big one it feels like a
gator oh god it's a giant blue
oh god please please stand there
this is a way bigger fish joe oh good
oh god
god
i don't like when they jump like that
man
give me the end of the rod
i need the end of the run
are you taking more line out
as far as you're going oh oh you got
past the swivel okay
nice fish oh nice fish this fish might
be 15 pounds but we won't know until i
get it in the boat
[Applause]
breaking everything up
this is unbelievable
look at the pogba grip for you
after so
much failure
so much failure
trying to catch this thing
and then having a good one on and it
coming off
man this is
joe this is what fishing's all about
staying with it right you got it never
giving up
man
this is unbelievable
this is exactly one of the reasons i've
come to new york city to catch a blue
fish
these things are eating machines they're
animals and i want you to take a look at
the
mouth and the teeth on that thing
absolute set of razor blades in its
mouth
destroying anything
it gets near
joe let's get a let's get a weight on
this thing
13 pounds that's it joe that's it baby
that is the gator that's a gator that is
official gator that is the biggest
blue fish
i've ever caught in my life
and i get to check this thing off my
bucket list joe what do you think can we
let this thing go absolutely we got more
to catch i'm gonna release this fish man
i'm stoked out of my mind swim at your
friends thank you fish
all right
nice going buddy joe thank you man all
right
second trip we fished together yeah
you're not letting me down
you're not letting me down
[Music]
yes
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
you